you're here how are you feeling about
the fact that your life is now a
situation where you go and you do big
interviews like this a lots changed for
you in a short amount of time I got my
biggest interview to date now here with
you the wonderful lauren zima
and so i'm excited to be here yeah I
mean life's different yeah it's been fun
it's been good I mean it's funny because
you're sitting here in this white
t-shirt now and I think you might have
worn a white t-shirt like in your intro
package for Hannah's season yeah I did
taking me back I mean when you were
filming that and just dancing around in
that construction did you ever think
that this much would happen for you no I
never thought it would blow up to this
extent I never thought you know the show
would become all that would become the
feelings that I felt like never thought
and but so grateful for the experience
it's been you know life-changing has
been the most amazing thing I've ever
been a part of like I'm super grateful
for yeah my whole experience you danced
around in that package a lot time yeah I
love the mess around and dance yeah no
doubt I thought we might see you on
Dancing with the Stars yeah yeah now I
got some other things I'm working on
yeah you know hopefully that comes out
soon we figured it out were you doing a
lot of modeling yep yeah that's going
really well yes we're cool campaigns
coming out too so excited for that I had
some editorials coming out just recently
and those were awesome shots and it's
going well what do you like about
modeling I'll tell you what the favorite
thing I like about modeling is the other
day I was doing the shoot it was for the
rap report and we were in a committee
van and you had to produce two producers
while most were margin Tina was from
Spain
he had a stylist from she was from San
Diego but the hair makeup was from Japan
and the photographer was from Russia and
it was all of us from different walks of
life all were together and just to hear
the stories and what people love to do
like you know talking about food and
everything it was just is this really
cool to everyone together and you know
just kind of brings people from all
walks of life together
Taylor I love that that's your answer I
mean most people would say I love the
camera being on me I love the lights I
love looking beautiful and you
I love the overall difference yeah no I
just love the people I've met I mean we
introduced to so many different people
than I've ever would be introduced to in
Jupiter Florida yeah and it's just been
amazing I've made so many great friends
and I've that's really truly why I like
enjoy so much
how is it getting fangirled over I would
imagine it's not easy to walk through
the streets of New York or anywhere
these days you have to get recognized it
can be a little overwhelming at times
but I will say that everyone's been
super awesome like super sweet I mean
everyone that's come up to me it's been
amazing and I'm very grateful for it I
was always obsessed with your amazing
speeches you made on the show I call
them you're respectful King speeches are
so good did you watch all of your season
back and and what did you think when you
were watching I've watched it as it came
out I never like I never haven't gotten
back and watched it again right yeah I
mean I've just me being me you know and
one thing I'm like you know proud of is
like my boys would call me all the time
like I'm glad you never like stepped out
of character you're always true to who
you are the whole time and and that's
how I was gonna be like I was never
gonna sell myself excuse you like me for
who I am and that's how it was going to
be yeah and you fell in love with Hannah
yeah she's an amazing girl like there's
there's you know I gave it my all and
she's she's incredible have you been
watching her on Dancing with the Stars
I've watched a little snip like snippets
I haven't been able to watch it I mean I
don't you have a TV in the city so like
when when I was when the show was going
on while as I said you I like you know
like race over to my friends house and
watch it you know so yeah now that you
know I just haven't been able to really
get to it but I've been watching like
the clips that come out and afterwards
she's killing it well in today's our
birthday yeah yeah she's a happy
birthday Hannah so is New York your home
now
yeah I be probably bouncing back and
forth between New York and floor like I
still want to be in construction so I'm
kind of working out you know the whole
situation I'm trying to possibly bring
on a partner to be my eyes and go back
and forth so you know construction is
still like a part of my life that I I
want to have and do and you know it's
something I truly love doing you know
it's a something that's tangible you
know something that you can get your
hands on and start from the ground up
there's a million pieces that going to
built in the house and I don't it's just
fascinating to me so you're gonna model
and do the construction again
great Tyler I give you credit I mean
most people when they get off the show
you know they don't think oh I still
want to do this other job and that's my
long-term goal is to have a construction
company and use this you know use what I
have now so beautiful to help fuel that
and and get that going
yeah all right well let's talk about
what else is going on in your life let's
do it are you in love with a supermodel
Tyler Cameron and I at the point where I
don't really want to talk about my
relationships I've dated publicly yeah
so I'm trying to you know date privately
and you know I mean I love anybody right
now I'm in love with myself being loved
with yourself I guess yeah that's a good
way to put it yeah well you know you had
that final drink with Hannah mm-hmm and
then we saw some very public photos of
you and Gigi Hadid yeah so where are you
guys at right now who you and Gigi uh
we're just we're just friends we're just
friends
hey sure yeah just where we're at you
know our relationship is need to be
public it's she's good she's good people
she's an amazing person and we're just
keeping it keeping it friendly well
here's the thing you have all these fans
who want you to be happy right it for
you yeah who probably wanted you to be
the bachelor yeah but it seems like you
you might be a little Buddha I mean I
did you went to Gigi's grandmother's
funeral with her which was beautiful so
it seems like you really care about her
yeah she's she's an amazing person we've
had a great time together we funk out a
few times I say yeah yeah we all watched
you on the finale get asked out for a
drink Hannah said have one more drink
with me so where were you at in that
moment mentally did you think about
getting back together with her was that
a real possibility yeah there's
definitely was emotion still there you
know she's an incredible person an
incredible girl and uh it was um you
know when she said let's get a drink it
was like I was already like figuring we
were gonna go get a drink and see each
other gee I mean one way or the other
we had to talk to him stuff out yeah so
it was uh you know she's it was it was
good to have you know see each other
well then we got some paparazzi photos
that looked like the drink had gone long
into the night yes that's photos to come
out no those I mean that's just that's
just me
I guess not understanding the world that
I was kind of thrown into yeah yeah it's
definitely been
I open her and you know you have to move
differently now and I don't know it just
never would never never I never came
across my mind I was a thing you know
just yeah the naive miss of me I guess
what was the thing you're the most glad
that you guys kind of talked out in that
night like did you figure out hey we're
not gonna move forward with this what
was the big takeaway when you did
finally talk things out and have that
drink
no just I mean we still care for each
other and she's an amazing person and
that you know there no there's no hard
feelings today yeah
but just good to like kind of yeah
exactly
well Hanna did she did a podcast and she
said that you had seemed to move on a
little bit quickly did you give her a
heads up like how did that I was gonna
still date people like I the whole time
I was on the show I really didn't go out
and date nobody didn't put myself out
there at all out of respect for her and
I don't respect to the show and so I was
like I still want to go put myself out
there and see what's right and what's
not right you know and that's all I was
really trying to do yeah I feel like
your person always just tries to do the
right thing yeah you know and I make
mistakes and you know there's things
there's definite things I should have
handled better but you know I never
meant to do anyone wrong and I just was
trying to figure out what was best for
me and where where my heart was that I
mean she told me she texted you about
your dad I think you guys seem like I'm
yeah exactly yeah I wished her a happy
birthday so you join the modeling thing
mm-hmm
is that keeping you super busy traveling
all over the world what's next with that
I got a really good really big campaign
coming out in January I got some other
things that are coming so I'm excited as
fun it's you know it's been crazy my
agency's getting pissed off because I
got I gotta get back in shape I have I
got hurt
I've like busted my knee up so I haven't
been able to run and do what I need to
be doing I have been eating too good
lately so I love those cookies so um
yeah I just you know we got to get back
to getting right and getting get my body
back together it's really funny to hear
you say that because I don't think
anyone so could we ever see
you walking down a runway like we just
had New York Fashion Week like are you
gonna are you a runaway guy or is it
just I don't know I mean I hopped in he
presents itself and it makes sense
you know possibly but I'm just I'm just
taking a day by day it's mom Molly's
been a blessing I've got great people in
my corner there that I love working with
so I mean I'm so new into that world of
the industry so I'm just you know having
fun with it making a name for myself if
I can and but it's like using as a
vehicle to get you know a team that goes
I won't obtain which is construction and
real estate so would you and your friend
Gigi ever model together
well she works in the industry do you
guys ever cross paths working uh no
she's a little bit more big time than I
am might be one of the biggest
supermodels in the world yeah she's
pretty good at what she does
you met Bella - right I mean do you have
you learned anything from them a been in
this industry a long time uh no I don't
really try to talk about that talk with
them I just try to enjoy the moment you
know again I loved your respectful King
speeches if you were gonna like say just
anything amazing and beautiful about
Gigi what would what would the speech be
she's great anything else that's great
no I had some ones leave it at that
okay I mean I could sit here and say
like she's gorgeous she's funny she's
accomplished she's all these things you
said for me see it agree yeah I can't
argue that can argue that he would she's
great when you're living this new life
has it been emotional for you to get
photographed a lot to experience that
side of things is it painful for you at
all
just not know if it's not so painful but
it's just you like I'm afraid to talk to
on the phone while I'm on the streets or
you know like it's definitely you have
to change the way you move and and I
don't know it's definitely makes it puts
a lot of pressure on things I don't need
to have pressure on them so like what
just anything in general you know like
everything everyone writes their own
narrative before you even get to figure
out what you're trying to fit you know
and so Debbie puts pressure on a lot of
things and whether it's relationships
whether it's life whether it's your
family you know it's crazy you the
narratives people come up with and I'm
just trying to
do the right thing am I in and just got
to do what makes you happy and
everything else will fall into place
what's been the toughest moment for you
through it all
maybe the lack of privacy being able to
just blend in so what have you learned
about how to protect yourself you know
you just you just have fun you just
can't you just can't let it affect you
know it is what it is and you know I
just surround myself with good people
and when it weighs on me I talked to
Matt and I talked to the people in my
life that are important and they like
dude don't even worry about it you know
like it's not your you know you can't
make I'll learn like you can't make
everyone happy
you just gotta make yourself happy and
the paparazzi still following you around
a lot no they leave me alone what are
you most grateful for having had this
experience like what are you glad that
you got out of it I learned a lot about
myself on that show I was like 10 weeks
of therapy it was you know you talk a
lot of things out you you learn a lot
about yourself and it's a mental game of
tennis we come back a fourth of like you
know getting in and out of your head
about things and it just gave me a lot
of like confidence moving forward of how
to handle things I just you know focus
on what's important and then everything
else will fall into place you happy now
oh I'm extremely happy you know wife's
life has changed for the better it's
great I mean I get to take my little
brother to Paris a couple of weeks like
these are things that I never would have
gotten to do you know you know I told my
dad the other day like right 10 things
down that you've always wanted to do and
like I'll make it happen
you know and it's just like I've been
given opportunities that you know and I
got a head start on life and it's
grateful and it's opened a lot of doors
for me and I want to just do goodbyes
and you know keep to pleasure you know
keep doing things with the kids that I
work with labor seafood tours and and
all that I'm just trying to keep putting
positive in the world did she ever do
reality TV again yeah in a certain way
in a certain world yeah we saw you
instagrams you had a meeting with Disney
ABC what's the meeting about I got a lot
of meetings going on right now I'm
working and see what I can put together
you know I'm just trying to have fun
with it take it day by day I'm working
with some great people so I'm excited
for the future you did have quite a
fandom honestly including myself hoping
I'm a fan you know so it goes both ways
I mean I'm glad this is finally
happening so you
sit here and grill the crap out of me
I'm catching it I'm catching it it's
getting hot over here we're getting a
little out in the black this is
different than when you're posted for
the photos I didn't want you to be the
bachelor was that ever offered to you
yeah something we talked about but where
I was at my life and when I was in my
life I just didn't think it was where I
wanted to be my heart wasn't it my dad
was really it was really sick and again
and I was kind of nervous and scared and
I just you know sat on it thought about
it and just you know my heart wasn't in
it
yeah how's your dad he's doing much
better now he's uh bouncing back and you
know it's tough because when you're in
New York you can you can hear in his
voice when he's not feeling good and
when he is feeling good so lately a lot
of her calls you didn't he's been
sounding really good so that's awesome
so I'm gonna get home to see him soon
well I'm sure you're doing what he'd
want you to do which is pursuing your
dreams and working hard yeah he's
definitely pushing me he's he's been an
amazing support system through this you
know there's times where you know I want
to just go home and hang out it seems
like not stay up there do what you got
to do hopefully I'll get him off to New
York soon he wants to see the leaves
change and all that so plan on getting
him up here soon I cried when you guys
on the show together that was such a
that's my guy that's my guy love me yeah
as he met the new lady so you turned
down the bachelor kind of for where you
were at was it also because you were
dating other people like was that part
of the decision yeah I mean I was you
know it's you shouldn't go on the show
if you have a girlfriend
so no I was if you're dating somebody or
seeing somebody you know but I just what
my heart wasn't you know 100% there and
that's something that you got it really
fully being invested in I think Peter is
gonna be amazing I'm excited to watch
Peter he's got so much joy like that
smile and he's got the subtle swagger
that I just love and I could door about
Peter he's just an incredible human
being so you guys seemed really close on
the show yeah I love he's great he's
great he's uh he needs to you know moved
to New York and be based out of New York
so I can see him more he was someone who
I mean he was in tears when Hannah broke
up with them what do you think he'll be
like is the bachelor fall hard emotional
I think you will fall hard for somebody
you know I may fall hard for a couple
people know
cuz I mean we saw with Hannah you know
and it's tough it's a very hard position
to be in and I think he's got such a
genuine heart that it's gonna hurt him
to say goodbye to people and and he's uh
but he's a class act and I mean look at
his family he comes from an amazing
family so how often do you think planes
will be incorporated into his dates I
think it'll be almost every other
episode was talking about planes could
you give us a message right to camera
for Peter Peter keep killing it brother
I'm proud of you I'm so stoked for you
find your girl real quick I just gotta
ask you about a Mike Johnson my
seemingly I mean he said taking Demi
Lovato out on a couple days that's
big-time
Mike Mike Mike Mike's a smooth operator
is he yeah he's got that smile he's got
a smile and there's those little
caterpillar eyebrows he's cute you know
maybe it may be a double date what do
you think we'll see we'll see
Mike's uh you know nice busy guy busy
guy yeah no I mean I'm happy for me
seems to be happy and living life you
know to the fullest I know you you know
part wanted to be the bachelor but it
seems like he's bouncing back all right
and it'll do just fine Mike's great
bouncing back with a superstar Demi
Lovato and I also want to ask you can we
get in a Tyler dance move just for the
memories Tyler dance move no just a
little dance move like just right to
[Laughter]
give you coffee
my last ask for you it's very selfish
Tyler but it's also for the people huh
you know I love the speeches can you two
camera just like give some love to the
fans like if you had a little speech to
the fan sort of followed you and put you
on the spot this is your new to everyone
I appreciate you I adore you
you guys have been so great to me and so
great with everything that's going on
but now it's time to get handed that
mirror ball so go vote for her and let's
get her that w this week of course he
makes it about somebody else okay thank
you for killer Cameron the best human
alive
[Music]